si le projet spatial le plus ambitieux
de la nasa depuis 1972 retourner sur la
lune et c'est maintenant officiel le
canada et deux astronautes seront de la
partie dans le cadre du programme
artemis on parle ici de défi d'une
grande complexité tant sur le plan
technique qu'humain
il va falloir construire des nouveaux
lanceurs des capsule habitable une
station orbitale autour de la lune et
bien sûr une véritable base lunaire
capable d'accueillir des astronautes
durant de longs séjours
si tout va bien en 2023 durant la
deuxième phase du programme artemis un
canadien participera un vol d'essai
autour de lui artemis deux quittent la
terre en orbite et on revient sur terre
une lourde épreuve du jour et il va y
avoir un canadien avant le bras canadien
il vit connaîtra une troisième vie cette
fois à bord de la station orbitale des
trous et qui se trouvera à 1000 fois
plus loin de la terre que la station
spatiale internationale
on va fournir une troisième mouture du
broc canadien qui va servir à
l'entretien et à capturer des pièces
d'équipement des cargos des choses comme
ça mais qui sera contrôlé à partir de la
terre
au fil des ans un programme de retour
sur la lune a connu plusieurs versions
différentes a été reporté à plusieurs
reprises et l'objectif ultime mars est
encore très lointain mais pour le canada
cette entente avec la nasa est une
excellente nouvelle
le canada a toujours été dans à l'avant
à l'avant scène à l'avant-garde de la
conquête spatiale
on était le troisième pays à lancer un
satellite dans l'espace
et donc là on serait le deuxième pays à
envoyer des astronautes dans des humains
vers laâyoune
reste maintenant à choisir parmi les
quatre astronautes canadiens qualifiés
dont david saint jacques qui participera
cette mission historique pour le pays
les normands grondin radio canada
montréal
[Musique]